so I'm Scott Carney I'm an investigative
journalist and I did a story for Wired
magazine about land mafia in Bangalore
and this is a story that I've been
looking over for the last three years
after I had seen reports and some
newspapers about murders of realtor's in
the city and I wanted to just lead you
through some of the characters of the
story that we didn't were quite have
space to bring out into into the piece
and that was in the magazine first you
see a photo of just some graffiti in the
city where it says land mafia crimes
traffic and there's a sort of a
political party slogan next to it I mean
this is just to give you an idea this is
the writing on the wall quite literally
it's a problem which really extends
right through Bangalore it's in the
public discourse everyone knows about
the land mafia and you know everyone has
stories about people who are beaten up
or had seen something like this happen
and everyone complains that there's no
transparency and land deals so this is
very much the writing on the wall other
things that show up on the walls are our
declarations of who owns particular
pieces of property and here's a couple
photos of that say things like this
property is not for sale
belongs to jsr raju or or you know any
other number of names that show up and
the reason they do this is when land
isn't developed indian law right now
allows people to come in and sit down on
that land and more or less just squat it
and take it over if they're there for a
certain number of years it belongs to
them and since real estate is one of the
major things that people invest in in
India squatters are actually a weapon of
the land mafia and you know where I
opened up the story with this piece of
farmland by the airport which was taken
over by goons the legitimate owner had
you know sort of had a farm
there and on the side of the farmhouse
it said this land belongs to Chabria
john juanny
what the goons did is they came over and
just painted over that sign to sort of
show that Chabria domani is not the
owner and they were going to manufacture
a legal dispute and once things go into
the courts the entire system breaks down
courts can take fifteen to twenty years
to mediate a land dispute and it doesn't
even matter if the claim is legitimate
or not if they get there it is pretty
much ruined it can take so long that to
get your money out of that investment
that it makes more sense to play ball
with the the crime figures and now
you'll see a photo of this you know
dapper looking bald gentleman his name
is agni sri there he is one of the
original Mafia dons in the city in the
90s he had killed a sort of one of the
largest dons of the city and and and
took over a lot of the land rackets now
he's now a reformed on and runs a
newspaper called Agni Patrika which
means fire newspaper and he is a sort of
a noted activist he's very leftist is
leanings and contributes a lot of money
to leftist political campaigns he was
also an associate of Metabo rai now when
I met him he's quite a quite an
interesting man to speak with he still
acknowledges that he makes most of his
money off of real estate and before I
actually went up to meet him he had was
sitting in a meeting with one of the
most well known builders in the city the
the chairman or maybe president of a
company called embassy builders it that
owns many many IT parks in the city is a
landlord to Microsoft and to Dell and to
some very big name companies he was just
having a meeting with them about land
deals and when I asked him about it he
just sort of smiled and says you know
I'm a man who knows a lot about about
Bangalore now when I'm downstairs
waiting for him I meet this other man
he's a gentleman with dark sunglasses
and his name is lil kesh malama and
malama means medicine and as in if
you've got a problem
Lokesh is the medicine and and he deals
primarily in land deals and while we're
speaking he tells me about a number of
murders that he'd committed in the 80's
and 90's and he laments the fact that
these days that guns are have entered
into the into the scene and that he is
just sort of aghast at the level of
violence in bangalore and i asked if he
had any weapons with him and he said
yeah sure i do and he opened up the
trunk of his car and there were like
these I don't know that looks like 10 or
15 swords and knives that he keeps with
him at all times just in case he has to
go murder someone or more likely
intimidate them off the land and know
this is with Agni Streeter the reformed
on sitting upstairs the whole time so
you know the collusion between these the
the powers of builders and this local
muscle is just very much in your face
right there on the street and now that's
where we come to Matata Rai himself who
is probably the most powerful person in
land deals in Bangalore right now is
worth several billion dollars and when
you come up to his estate he's
surrounded by guards who have sawed-off
shotguns who are aiming to protect his
mansion and him he's been shot five
times in a in a sort of while he was up
for charges of extortion a man raid
dressed as a lawyer came in and shot him
while he was in the court room
the assassin or the attempted assassin
didn't live too much longer after that
attempt next day they brought me to the
court the goal to somebody shot me he
shot me five minutes right there is not
a Indian pistol US Army pistol the four
five bullets I see is this much five
bullet in the point to plant one is come
entered here passed through oh my god
entered here pass it through stop
earlier do yes I was ready do you in in
that forty years yeah but now you're
fine you can know how imperfect the
waked well I can jump again dance
hahahaha you know he's actually a very
nice man to me he's very jovial and and
and actually sort of an entertaining guy
fun-loving and you really would never
want to cross it normally the wall the
hotel people are giving the money to
those people fooled us right Virginia I
not I didn't agree I didn't give for
them afterwards they all killed you kill
them are here they are here they are
gonna kill they were killed with my
support maybe with your support yeah and
and and that was the eighties yeah
the time I see after they after all oily
eliminate publicly told I am the wrong
the way I understand it and the way most
people talk about it is he isn't
involved in in outright violence all
that much anywhere because his name
alone is enough to scare people off now
a lot of people will connect small
instances of violence and extortion to
him and there are many many allegations
of murders and Rowdies and and and sort
of thugs connected to him and you know
the sort of the evidence on the ground
is
he's a pretty bad man but he has beaten
all of the charges in the Indian courts
now that's where we come to the loci
okhta who's this man Santosh Hegde who's
just a a retired Supreme Court justice
in Bangalore and what he has done is or
what his position is is the leader of
the anti-corruption squad in in
Bangalore and he investigates instances
of people taking bribes all government
officials usually and any sort of
corruption within the system and he's a
very busy man he busts at least one
person a day and he has accumulated
almost a billion dollars worth of
illegal assets they take money from
others as extortion money they threaten
them your life is in danger if you don't
do this if we don't sell this property
to me of my agent or somebody whom I
want you to sell it to right then take
for granted you will not say that they
like tomorrow when I spoke to
day he said yeah I can get you a clear
title to anything very quickly right
they know and I just don't you know
because I have the best lawyer as he
says that that is best lawyers of maybe
in the form of the best written 30 days
unfortunately he is unable to prosecute
any of these people because the the
parameters of his position is that he
has to report to senior levels of the
government in order to arrange any of
his prosecutions and since a lot of the
senior members of the government are
taking bribes in the first place they
don't want to give him the power to
prosecute themselves so it's a lot like
asking the Fox for the keys to the
henhouse you know it he he doesn't have
a shot really
in the meantime people like madaba Ryan
and band ignition reader and whoever
else in the city has pretty much a free
rein on the city to control the justice
system and also in make huge profits off
of the booming real estate